just want to start with the story that
the government has just
changed the quarantine rules on spain a
reminder really about how quickly things
can change in the pandemic
is it sensible for people to be booking
foreign holidays
well i mean it'll be up to people to
decide if this is the right time for
them to do that i'm
supportive of what the government's done
if they're following the science we're
all here to
protect each other and save lives and if
that's what they've had to do that's
what they've had to do
but i i think there is a broader concern
here about the general strategy that the
government has been employing
over the last few weeks we saw the prime
minister just this week suggest that
mistakes were made and that's why i'm
leading this cross-party group of mps
we're running a rapid
inquiry into coronavirus right through
recess so that we can learn the lessons
that we need to
before a potential second wave yeah
that's the
key thing i guess isn't it trying to get
the country prepared for what may be
coming down the line
in the autumn and winter months when the
nhs is already under more pressure
from what you've heard in the inquiry do
you think that we are ready yet
well we don't know we've just started we
constituted a couple of weeks ago
we've now got over 50 mps and peers from
all across the house
including conservative mps and we've
had written submissions in so far over a
thousand of them in fact
the vast majority have come from
individuals who
are suffering from long-lasting effects
of coronavirus they call it long coved
so they've had coronavirus and
it continues to light their lives on a
daily basis
the other big group that's written in on
an individual basis are bereaved
families who
you know tragically one of their own has
passed away and i'm really concerned
about the mental health support around
them they don't feel that their voices
have been heard
and this is going to be a way for them
to to have that
uh have that outlet but there's also
been well over 20 professional bodies
that have written in
and there have been some really striking
uh
pieces of evidence one from age uk
for example that said that older people
in receipt of care in care homes
especially have been catastrophically
let down and many have died
before their time that's what we're here
to try and avoid
is that before the second wave those
mistakes are understood
and the big question the man that we're
starting with we're going to be having
by the way
live streaming of our evidence sessions
that start on wednesday we want this to
be completely transparent and if people
want to watch in they should be able to
and the first question we need to answer
is what is the government's overall
strategy
we've seen other countries including in
the united kingdom
say that they are aiming for what's
termed zero covert zero transmission
in the community of coronavirus and
they've done that through
putting things in place like a proper
test and trace system that works from
start to finish
social distancing and clamping down on
things like that earlier
we have not heard from boris johnson
if that is what he is aiming for in
england and the whole of the united
kingdom
and that is one of the big questions
because if we aren't aiming for zero
covet before the autumn
then what do we need to do to make sure
that the nhs is prepared so we've just
started we are going to release
recommendations as we go
with a full report that will then sum
all of that up by the end of september
but our view is that we cannot wait
okay uh thank you for the run through
what the
inquiry is hoping to achieve now before
we came on in the introduction
and i think we really i guess laid out
the challenge
ahead for the liberal democrats you of
course running to be a
leader of your party a lot's changed
since you announced your bid
on the show a few months ago um is the
survival
of the liberal democrats at stake here
well i think that's possible and i think
actually
we need revived liberalism in this
country which is the
the core part of my pitch you know it's
now been three general elections in a
row
we're bumping along at six percent in
the polls
change has never been more necessary in
fact it's essential
for the survival of our party and what i
want to do as leaders to reverse that
decline
and it starts by actually having a bold
progressive
liberal agenda that we can show the
country and actually coronavirus
as awful as the circumstances are
actually
shows us that there should be and could
be another way
in this country has exposed the
inequalities that we see before our very
eyes
and the civil liberties of the
individual the freedom of us
all um has come under some strain
now is the time for a revived liberal
democrat party and that's very much
central to my pitch
okay um i'm trying to uh answer the
question i guess a lot of people
probably have which is you know
what are the lib dems about what's the
point of them what do they stand for
now you suggested last month that you
wanted to move the lib benz to the left
you said
i wanted to be seen as more radical than
labour the manifesto you're publishing
today calls for things like a universal
basic income but then earlier this month
you said
i don't want us to be on the left of
labour so i'm a bit confused
do you want the lib dems to be a more
left-wing party or not
i want us to be more radical so when i
said more radical than labor that was
not left
it was radical liberalism and i think
that's what i found
interesting about the conversations
around this is that actually that left
right axis
doesn't work when you think about
liberalism on the one hand
we have a strong commitment to public
services because you need as an
individual the security
to live life as you choose and that's
why we talk about you know changes to
universal credit having a welfare system
that stops people from falling through
the cracks but on the other hand
we are a friend to business i also want
the party to make sure that
we are on the side of business on the
side of entrepreneurs
in my manifesto that's released today i
talk about
looking at the economy and making it
work particularly for small business
that's not left that's not right that's
liberal and core
to my uh three pillars of the campaign
and when i when i came on in uh
on your show just a few months ago i
spoke about making us the party of
education again
talking about the environment these are
two very important things but the third
pillar that i've added since then
is around the economy we have huge
challenges that our country is going to
face over the next months and years
and this is the opportunity to make sure
that the economy isn't just measured in
terms of growth and gdp
but that we also put other indicators
around it like mental health and
well-being so there is another way
of having our country thrive and it's a
liberal way not left not right
okay now it hasn't been the smoothest
start to your leadership campaign
uh that you could have wished for you
had to delete a tweet which mimicked her
style was
character that some people thought was
racist he deleted a potentially libelous
claim against the housing secretary
robert gemerick
figures you collated about children
admitted to hospital with malnutrition
turned out to be wrong
do you think some people might be
wondering if you've really got the
judgment to be a lib dem leader
well there are no perfect campaigns
mistakes have been made on both sides
in this leadership election but what we
are also finding is that core message
is bringing people towards us and what i
would say though
is we have to win back trust with the
voters you know this is the big thing
that we need to now
do and we also need to show them that we
are
credible over the last few weeks i've
delivered the coronavirus compensation
scheme
cross party you know this is a scheme
that
helps bereaved families of nhs frontline
social care
and nhs workers we need to show people
that the point of voting libdem right
now
is to have someone who can get stuff
done
for them and their family in a way
that's really palpable i've shown that i
have
the ability to do that i've shown that i
can get cut through in the media
to get that message across at a time
when people are wondering where the lib
dems have gone
this is a really critical moment for our
party and unless we change and unless we
move forward together
then i'm seriously concerned about the
future of the party and that's why i'm
encouraging people to vote for me
the momentum in this campaign is very
much with me
and the last internal poll had me
slightly ahead